[Music]
so what is this kid's favorite planet is
let's check it out and and can we
confirm that I'm right about urine the
Uranus pronunciation I would actually
like to know if that's true too
favorite planet
[Music]
but it's true
what did he say that's not like the
butthole like
like this
why is that your favorite planet
wow he's really honest with himself and
others I like that he I like that he
discerned like it's not I don't my
butthole the butthole part isn't my
favorite yeah it's the planet but it's
because it has exactly exactly wait can
I throw a tip Tick Tock up there is
there no oh I'm obsessed absolutely with
this Tick Tock right now wait let's see
there's this one right now that is just
killing me
oh wow it doesn't even have a Uranus
option so the scientific Community would
like people to say Uranus so it's less
childish but the proper pronunciation is
Uranus the scientific Community is
always on my ass
this guy who [__] named it that in
the first place I don't know exactly
that was someone from the scientific
Community right wait can I pee again
during this yeah
how was it pee oh it was incredible good
you guys have some really good smelling
soap in there too it's like Dove weird
thing to do after you get back from the
bathroom just smell your fingers all
right let's get started
um no you guys have some cucumber melon
Dove uh Foaming Hand Soap in there
really oh yeah we like to do it really
great yes we export that from Earth
is this this guy there's this
pronunciation guy on YouTube is like
today we are learning to say this world
have you heard it and literally you look
up pronounced anything it's like today
yeah it's like how did this guy get like
calling the market on this is got to be
French so he says he pronounces
everything in a French accent yeah then
it's like yeah you were the expert yeah
congrats yeah we are looking at how
that's him oh yeah
third largest planetary radius and the
fourth largest planet from the solar
system we are looking at how to
pronounce this isn't this is AI for sure
this voice is not real it's a lot like
Celine Dion
it rather than on the second one and say
Uranus rather than Uranus
Uranus and correct
okay can you play that Tick Tock that I
sent and then play Brian's
you see this one
who is this wait what is that what does
the caption say
okay okay it's just the best sound bite
in the world okay I'm using this in a
song
how many children do you have 23 22 baby
a real bad man
wow 23 22 baby mama real bad man
who is that guy he's a real Batman wow
he's incredible yeah so this is the one
that you yeah yeah I just love this tick
tock
all right
now the plastic bag over here that's
gonna pop
[Music]
you ain't out into a plastic bag and I
can't even get a Walmart bag to hold two
two liters
once you get that bag from
show me a man cook your meal
yes
[Music]
five minute music yeah I forward
I need some of y'all to hold on like
that bag is holding all them ingredients
hold on because Hep is on his way don't
give up you ain't saw that bad giving in
half you don't matter how hard things
make it how much is powered on top of
you you can endure look at that bag
bless it
I just love and also what is it what a
deal with that what the [__] kind of bag
is that I don't know I feel like that
food is probably not edible because it's
like plastic yeah yeah melted plastic in
it I know and it's such a funny
combination of Aesthetics like out in
nature with all these natural products
and you're like cooking your meal and a
plastic bag is definitely melting into
your meal like just cook it in a pot
what are we doing here
this is it oh this is the instructions
on how to cook like this ancient what is
it is it ancient Chinese animal no
ancient Chinese
how is that plastic bag not burning yeah
what's the answer
what is that [__] thing
that's an incredible plastic bag that's
an amazing way to like make soup this is
like a soup bag
yeah soup bag for sure for sure
um we were I was talking to
Noel and who else were talking about
bongs with remember
I forget when this was it might have
been last week might have been the week
before but I when I used to like be into
smoking weed as like a teenager I my
friends and I
made our own Bong by
like burning holes in two liter soda
bottles oh and then like gluing like P
like hose the doctor can still see that
in your lungs yeah exactly did you and
we like would smoke it before like the
glue set so we're like inhaling fumes of
burnt plastic and glue do you know what
I did what maybe you did this I would
use a light bulb to smoke weed I never
did that you cut the you cut the the
thing
I don't know what's it called the screw
top thing you so you cut it off which
seems like it's like how did I do that
because how do you you have to cut
screeching into metal and glass yeah
you're sort of cutting metal at that
point okay yeah and then you put the
weed in there and you burn it from
outside and it swirls this is a meth
pipe that's exactly yeah and people used
to be like I don't think people usually
smoke weed this yeah more power to you
but I was sort of uh yeah I this is how
I smoked weed back when I before I got
sober yeah
look at that yeah and then you put the
bottle cap on and the little you can use
a little straw or not but yeah similarly
it's just like they're about 1100 toxins
involved that are like you know yeah
because aren't gonna kill you some sort
of like uh you know some sort of
filament yeah well there's light bulbs
yeah yeah you wash all that out yeah
okay yeah you get it nice and clean but
I mean why why even bother I could I
know it's a nice high I didn't have that
yeah right exactly just smoke what's
already in yeah yeah the chemicals and
stuff I did it's just so funny I didn't
have the money to like buy I guess I
would have a pipe sometimes but yeah I
was so broke in college sometimes I
remember I don't know I don't know if I
talked about this before on here but I
was like I remember people would like go
out to eat in college they'd be like
we're all going to a restaurant that
would just be like where are they
getting the funds for these meals I'm
like I can go to the like the school
cafeteria or like eat these groceries I
have in the house but I just didn't
because I didn't have a job I wasn't one
of these people that was also working a
job during college I was just at college
and I had whatever
whatever money I had at that point